du coup
chaque semaine audrey brook enchaîne
cinq ou six séances de sport pour
préserver un physique qui lui a permis
de gagner le titre de miss paris la
jeune femme d'un mètre 70 s'entraîne
sans relâche fille mais quatre ans j'ai
même pratiqué du foot
j'ai joué au foot j'ai fais de
l'athlétisme
donc pour moi c'est essentiel c'est j'ai
fait de la danse également
donc j'ai jamais jamais il achète le
sport c'est vrai que pendant mes études
j'avais un peu plus de mal à être
assidus mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
bon ça fait partie de mon quotidien
c'est quelqu'un admettons ne pratique
pas de sport ou que quelqu'un me suis
pas ou on n'aime pas ça c'est même dans
mes amis c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
à comprendre
remarqué lors du salon de l'automobile
alors qu elle était hôtesse
on lui propose de défiler pour l'oréal à
cette époque l'illinois semaine encore
des études en alternance et décroche un
master en management spécialisation
marketing
elle décide ensuite de tourner la page
et se lance dans le concours de top
model reine
je suis arrivé dans les deux dernières
sur 6000 quand dieu qui met participants
au népal ils ont fait un casting dans
toute l'europe
moi j'ai passé le casting le casting à
lille ça arrivait donc dans le dans les
10 dernières donc déjà fait un énorme
tremplin donc là ça s'est passé
mars 2007 et ensuite par la suite j'ai
continué donc là je me suis lancé j'ai
des propositions aux démarques de
fitness on l'a fait à miami ne s'est pas
concrétisé tout un peu long des marques
des fidèles donc là j'ai eu des salles
de sport pour faire leur publicité donc
dans le sport essentiellement depuis
miss paris enchaîne les pubs les
chroniques radios les shootings photos
encore les clips comme son apparition
dans le clip de niel scène un artiste
r'n'b
[Musique]
moi j'ai envie de meo
à 26 ans elle se consacre à sa passion
elle est aujourd'hui l'égérie de
l'institut relooke une beauté minceur à
coignières pour qui elle enchaîne les
séances au tout alors audrey s'est
présenté en tant que cliente dans les
tout premiers jours où j'ai ouvert
l'institut et puis en discutant avec
elle je me suis rendu compte du couffin
elle m'a dit qu'elle était miss paris
depuis 2016
et puis en discutant on s'est dit que ça
pouvait être bien de faire un
partenariat pour l'ouverture de mon
institut donc audrey me semblait très
sympathique des séances photos
importante pour aude reybrouck il faut
il faut une vision médiatique puisque
bon bah moi on voit voilà fut médiatisée
mais surtout je suis figée en photo on
peut voir en qui mais là on voit pas ma
vie on voit vraiment l'oseraie brook là
aujourd'hui c'est audrey brook les
langes et donc à la audrey entre
guillemets là non pas la miss mais la
audrey et là c'est une importance
puisqu'on relais on voit ma vie on voit
aussi les côtés d'audrey donc c'est
important pour les personnes qui me
suivent de voir et d'apprendre à me
connaître également quand je fais du
sport par exemple ou lors d'un shooting
en fin d'année la miss paris 2016 sera
l'ambassadrice de la france au concours
miss planète